salut bienvenue dans ce nouveau h rad
une histoire un peu à l'ancienne un peu
à la bellemar mais là sur un fond
historique puisqu'on va parler de l'un
des plus gros scandales de l'Allemagne
dans les années
80 on va commencer cette histoire en
Allemagne de l'Ouest dans les années 60
imaginez un homme qui s'appelle Conrad
Cujo c'est un homme de magouille il a la
chat il s'invente des vies en permanence
il a même eu un bar quand il avait ce
bar là avec sa femme il avait changé son
Pr nom et son nom de famille il faisait
croire qu'il s'était fait persécuter
avant il s'invente des vies à l'époque
de ce restaurant il fait plein de
magouille via les ticket restaurant il
se fait attraper il va faire un petit
peu de prison il va sortir et la sa
sortie de prison avec sa Fan il
réfléchissent qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
faire on pourrait ouvrir une société de
nettoyage c'est ce qu'ils font dans la
légalité sauf qu'il n'y a pas de client
mais Conrad a toujours les oreilles bien
grandes ouverte et il s'aperçoit qu'en
ce moment il y a une très forte demande
pour des tableaux pour des tableaux qui
représentent des scènes de guerre et ça
tombe bien parce que Conrad a un petit
talent naturel pour le dessin donc il se
met à faire des tableaux de scènes de
guerre de scène glorieuse de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale où on voit ses clients à
l'intérieur du tableau ça se vend
extrêmement bien très très cher ça
c'était pour que vous ayez un petit peu
les contours du bonhomme voir un peu de
qui il s'agit en 1970 il va se rendre de
l'autre côté en Allemagne de l'Est pour
rendre visite à sa famille et une fois
là-bas il s'aperçoit que malgré
l'interdiction des autorités beaucoup de
personnes ont conservé des souvenirs des
reliques de l'époque nazi des uniformes
des documents des casquettes des armes
aussi mais Conrad sait qu'il y a une
très forte demande de ce genre d'objet
de de collection interdit de l'autre
côté de l'Allemagne de l'Ouest donc il
achète au marché noir énormément de ce
genre de chose de ce genre d'objet et il
est revant côté Allemagne de l'Ouest en
multipliant le prix par 10 c'est illégal
évidemment puisque l'Allemagne de l'Est
a interdit l'exportation de tout objet
intérieur à 1945 en 1974 la situation
financière du couple cuugot est
florissante ça fonctionne très très bien
il fait ses allers-retours il fait ses
ça ça fonctionne tellement qu'il y a
trop d'objets dans l'appartement de
Conrad et de sa femme donc il décide de
transformer le local de leur entreprise
de nettoyage qui somme toutes très très
peu de clients en un lieu de rendez-vous
nocturnes pour faire ses ventes d'objets
avec des clients fidèles qui sont
principalement des personnes qui sont
nostalgiques de l'époque nazie il y en a
des anciens militaires chefs de police
escrot magistrat et cetera et son
business marche c'est très rentable la
demande augmente de plus en plus via un
bouche à oreille dans ce milieu-là
tellement qu'il a pas assez d'objet pour
sa revendre donc il va commencer par
introduire des faux objets datant
soi-disant de l'Allemagne naasie pour
commencer à les vendre il a pas trop de
scrupule à le faire hein il se dit
puisqu'ils sont assez fous pour
glorifier cette période ils veulent des
objets je vais le rendonné il va aller
un petit peu plus loin il va augmenter
le prix de vente en commençant à
fabriquer de faux certificats de
d'authenticité par exemple un ancien
casque de militaire de soldat devient un
casque militaire ayant été porté par
Hitler lui-même et il va commencer à
produire également de fausses lettres
issues de grandchef de l'Allemagne Nazi
comme par exemple himler ou Borman il va
imiter leur leur style d'écriture il va
imiter également leur signature et bien
sûr il va les vendre comme authentique
mais le plus étonnant c'est que son
travail est pas terrible on peut même
dire qu'il est nul c'est très grossier
il utilise un type de papier qui
n'existait même pas à l'époque dans les
années 30 ou au début des années 40 pour
faire semblant que c'est du vieux papier
il va juste le tremper un petit peu dans
des feuilles de thé il il y a plein
d'anachronismes d'ailleurs dans les
lettres qu'il écrit mais peu importe
personne s'en rend compte alors soit
tout le monde est crédule soit ils sont
tellement fascinés par cette époque là
de l'Allemagne que ils sont contents
d'avoir la lête quoi qu'il arrive et
puis Comand bien même si quelqu'un avait
des doutes c'est interdit donc personne
va aller chez un expert pour
l'authentifier par la suite mais Conrad
en a jamais assez alors je suis pas sûr
est- est-ce qu'il en a jamais assez ou
est-ce qu'il se laisse griser par les
possibilités de ce qu'il entreprend le
fait est qu'il se fait un raccourci très
simple dans sa tête il se dit puisque
Hitler était peintre je vais fabriquer
des toiles peintes par Hitler d'autant
plus qu'il est de notoriété publique
après avoir raté l'école des beauards de
Vienne Hitler aurait produit entre 1907
et 1913 des centaines de d'œuvres
différentes des toiles des dessins des
cartes postales qui n'ont jamais été
vraiment recensé et comme Hitler était
pas très bon en peinture il faisait des
choses plutôt simples donc c'est encore
plus facile de les reproduire pour
Conrad alors il va faire des nus il va
faire des scènes de guerre il va faire
des paysages il fait un petit peu tout
il va même aussi se faire quelques
lettres signées soi-disant de la main
d'Hitler pourevendre tous ses documents
sans surprise le prix s'envolle et
Conrad monte encore d'un cran il décide
d'apprendre la calligraphie pourquoi
parce qu'il va recopier à la main les
deux volumes de MCF il va faire croire
que c'est le document original écrit par
le fureur lui-même évidemment il va les
mettre à la vente il va même aller un
peu plus loin que ça il va écrire un
troisième volume inédit que lui a en sa
possession le plus étonnant c'est qu'il
est une autoriété publique qu'à l'époque
Hitler avait dactylographier ces
documents mais passons il y a toujours
un acheteur pour ce genre de chose il le
vend à son plus fidèle client son plus
grand
collectionneur en 1978 Conrad décide
d'écrire les carnets intimes d'Hitler
l'idée ne lui vient pas comme ça en 1945
quand Hitler comprend qu'il a perdu la
guerre ses proches lancent l'opération
seraglio cette opération consiste à
évacuer toutes les affaires personnelles
d'Hitler et de ses proches mais l'un des
avions transportant les affaires du
furur va s'écraser et faire 16 morts à
l'intérieur de cet avion il y a beaucoup
d'affaires personnelles d'Hitler il
témoignerra que sa plus grosse déception
c'est qu'à l'intérieur de cet avion il y
avait tout ces carnets intimes toutes
ces retranscriptions de tout ce qu'il
avait fait et vécu quand l'avion s'est
écrasé il a brûlé et rien n'a pu être
sauvé des flammes mais pour Conrad cujot
c'est très simple il suffit de dire que
les carnets ont été retrouvés dans une
malle qui avait été secrètement sauvé
des flammes Cujo va au supermarché il
achète des carnets vous avez vu je vous
le disais au tout début de cette vidéo
il prend pas trop de gants il est pas
très méticuleux dans sa manière de faire
d'ailleurs sur ses carnets il va coller
avec du décalcomanie non pas les
initiales d'Hitler ce qui aurait dû être
le cas ah mais FH pour fureur et ça ça
aurait pu être la preuve directe de son
escrquerie mais bizarrement ça va passer
personne va faire attention à
l'intérieur de ses carnets il va
recopier les discours public d'Hitler et
il va rajouter des petites réflexions
personnelles quelques déclarations
supplémentaires tujo va écrire 27
carnets et il va en vendra à l'un de ses
clients les plus fidèles dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure le collectionneur
il s'appelle Fritz Stiefel mais Fritz ce
coup-ci décide d'aller faire
authentifier le carnet et puis quelques
peintures aussi qu'il avait acheté à
Conrade alors il connaît un expert qui
apparemment pas très regardant sur la
loi et cet expert est soi-disant
spécialiste de la période de l'Allemagne
Nazi l'expert prend le carnet le sculpte
et dit que c'est l'un des témoignages
les plus importants qu'il ait pu tenir
entre ses mains et concernant les
tableaux les aquarelles il va jurer
avoir tenu l'une d'elles entre ses mains
en 1936 alors que Conrad vient de
terminer de la peindre il y a 10 jours
jusqu'au jour où l'existence même de ses
Carné vont tomber dans l'oreille d'un
journaliste il s'appelle edeman il
travaille pour le plus gros journal de
l'époque il s'appelle le Stern néanmoins
c'est c'est pas quelqu'un qui est
vraiment admiré dans son métier pourtant
on lui reconnaît des qualités il a
beaucoup de sang-froid sur le terrain
beaucoup de courage et quand il fait des
enquêtes il va jusqu'au bout et dem man
connaît également certaines personnes il
côtoie beaucoup d'anciens haut
responsables nazis il a même une
relation avec EDA Goring la fille de
Herman Goring un des dirigeants du plan
nazi seulement le journal du Stern est
plutôt socialiste donc tout ce qui a
rapport surtout un rapport obsessionnel
avec l'emagne Naisy ils sont pas pour
donc il demande aux journalistes
d'arrêter complètement de creuser cette
piste là et ses recherches mais c'est
trop tard il a déjà rencontré le grand
collectionneur le plus fidèle client de
Conrade c'est lui d'ailleurs qui lui a
parlé des carnets et à partir de ce
moment-là le journaliste va vouloir
parler à la personne qui est en
possession de ces 27 carnés en 1981
Conrad coujot se fait appeler Fisher
c'est un nom d'emprin qu'il avait déjà
utilisé à l'époque où il avait son bar
il va rencontrer le journaliste qui va
lui demander comment il est rentré en
possession de ses documents donc il va
expliquer que c'est son frère qui a
retrouvé l'avion qui s'est écrasé
pendant l'opération qui a sauvé la malle
et qu'à l'intérieur de la malle il y
avait plein de choses il y avait les les
carnets intime d'Hitler il y avait
également le trisième volume inédit de
minecf avec les deux autres originaux
écrits de la main d'Hitler qui avait
plusieurs tableaux des aquarelles des
cartes postales quelques lettres
manuscrites et qu'ensuite il a exfiltré
tout ça pour le faire rentrer en
Allemagne de l'Ouest alors le
journaliste va lui faire une proposition
directe même si le journal lui a
interdit de travailler sur le 3è richich
il est trop historique trop important de
rentrer en possession de ces documents
et d'avoir l'exclusivité ils vont lui
proposer 2 millions de dutchmk avec une
avance immédiate de 200000 dutchmk ce
qui est considérable à l'époque et bien
sûr la garantie de préserver l'anonymat
de Fisher et ça c'est très important
pour Conrad parce qu'il risque
clairement sa vie puisqu'il a expliqué
que c'est lui-même qui avait exfiltrer
ces documents de l'Allemagne de l'Est à
l'Allemagne de l'Ouest ed deman sait que
les dirigeants du Stern vont refuser de
financer cet achat là et de poursuivre
l'enquête sur tous ces documents donc
edeman va voir directement la maison
mère qui possède en fait le Stern et qui
qui édite indirectement le Stern et va
aller voir l'un de ses dirigeants qu'il
connaît pour lui expliquer toute cette
histoire et ce dirigeant va sauter sur
l'occasion évidemment bah accepter de
financer mais de mal à des conditions le
propriétaire de la malle ne devra
traiter qu'avec lui il veut également
que les rédacteurs en chef du Stern soi
complètement mis à l'écart de cette
affaire là et dernière exigence pas des
moindres il refuse qu' a une expertise
sans son
accord le dirigeant de la maison mère du
Ster va accepter d'acheter l'ensemble
pour 3 millions de dutchmk 3 millions de
de plus de ce que edeman a promis à
l'achat à notre ami Conrade que faire de
ce million supplémentaire ben c'est très
très simple ça va rester dans les poches
du journaliste dans les poches d'Edman
qui dès le départ je pense avait décidé
à la fois d'escroquer l'escroc et à la
fois d'escroquer le dirigeant de la
maison m ce qui explique la condition
des de Man qu'il n'y ait pas d'expertise
sans son autorisation le premier carnet
est livré en 1981 puis il y aura deux
carnets qui arriveront chaque mois mais
avec difficulté et deman explique qu'à
chaque fois il y a des problèmes de
transition des choses à payer des choses
à régler ça a l'air très très compliqué
mais comme c'est complètement illégal il
y a pas de reçu il y a pas de facture il
y a pas de justificatif c'est donc très
facile pour edeman d'invoquer des choses
qui n'existent pas pour récupérer des
fonds supplémentaires le journaliste
change de vie BMW décapotable un duplexe
du côté de Hambourg bon on voit sa
richesse il s'en sert il a dépense du
côté de Conrade coujo c'est la même tout
va très bien financièrement il achète
même d'ailleurs un appartement dans
lequel il loge la maîtresse qu'il a
commencé à fréquenter et puis tant que
ça marche pourquoi pas en profiter d'un
coup Conrade coujo dit attention en fait
on a retrouvé d'autres carnets il y en a
pas 27 mais il y en a 60 à la fin de
l'année 1982 Gruner et Jard la maison
mer duisterern ont dépenser 7 millions
de dutchmk donc ça fait à peu près 4
millions de dollars pour le moment pour
faire la acquisition de tout ce qu'on
leur apporte tous les mois à ce
moment-là aucun carnet n'a été publié
dans la presse ou dans le journal du
Stern il préfère tout garder secret et
publ une fois que tout sera en leur
possession en 1983 le dirigeant de
Gruner rjard décide qu'il faut un peu
rentabiliser tout ça ça devient
compliqué il faut commencer à publier
les carnets d'autant plus qu'il commence
à y avoir des fuites un petit peu de
rumeurs et le scoop va être éventé donc
il veut prendre les devant le dirigeant
décide donc de faire authentifier contre
la vie des Dean il ils l'ont pas mais
ils vont y aller quand même mais ils
veulent pas que le scoop soit inventé
pour de bon alors voici ce qu'il va
faire il va fournir des photocopies pas
les originaux ça veut dire qu'il y aura
juste une expertise graphologique et il
y aura pas d'expertise chimique qui sera
possible et puis il va falloir comparer
cette graphologie donc ils leur
fournissent d'autres documents ces
autres documents sont des lettres
étaient écrites soisant par hler mais
qui sont aussi des lettres de Conrade
donc l'expert va comparer du faux avec
du faux évidemment il leur disent pas
qui s de documents écrit par éclair mais
juste de documents historiquees alors en
comparant l'écriture de Conrade avec
l'écriture de Conrade ben les experts
déclarent que c'est authentique le Stern
commence à négocier des droits à
l'étranger des droits de publication en
Angleterre aux États-Unis et même en
France d'ailleurs ils avaient entamé des
négociations entre le Stern et Paris
Match le 22 avril 1983 le Stern annonce
l'existence de ces carnets et leur
publication imminente sous peu mais les
véritables experts et les historiens
sont très étonnés déjà il était notori
été publique que Hitler détestait écrire
qu'il avait une très mauvaise syntaxe et
que sa maladie de Parkinson empêchait
l'existence de tel document après 1942
enfin d'autres affirment que l'explosion
et le feu qui avait détruit l'avion
avait été si fort qu'il est impossible
que le moindre document est résisté le
journal du Stern les experts qui avaient
authentifié à l'époque les photocopies
commencent à avoir des doutes alors les
dirigeants du Stern vont convoquer le
journaliste Edan pour lui demander de
révéler sa source ficher cujot Conrade
évidemment le journaliste refuse 3 jours
plus tard le 25 avril conférence de
presse l'ambiance est tendue tout le
monde est extrêmement sceptique David
hving un historien va soulever deux
problèmes qui seront reportés tout
d'abord aucun test chimique n'a été fait
et ensuite une page du carnet datée du
20 juillet 1944 le jour de l'attente
raté contre Hitler qui a été blessé au
bras et qui n'aurait donc pu jamais
écrire suite à cela le Stern est obligé
d'envoyer des carnets un autre expert un
véritable expert reconnu tris carnets
vont être envoyés le résultat est sans
appel il s'agit de faux de contrefaçon
sauf que pour le Stern et pour le groupe
c'est insoutable de penser qu'ils ont
perdu non pas 7 millions on était déjà
monté à 9 millions de dutchmk ils sont
en pleine dissonance cognitive ils
refusent cette expertise et ils vont
continuer à soutenir que c'est de
l'authentique du vrai un deuxième expert
un graphologue fait une autre expertise
et donne un compte-rendu le 4 mai une
expertise graphologique pour dire qu'il
a pas fallu longtemps pour voir que
c'était complètement faux et avant même
que le Stern puisse faire une
publication officielle le gouvernement
prend les devants et fait une annonce
publique dans les médias pour dire que
toute l'histoire des carnets est faux et
que ça n'existe pas suite à cette
annonce officielle Conrad pafou s'enfuit
tout de suite en Autriche il emporte sa
femme et sa maîtresse avec lui mais et
c'est là la complexité du personnage
quelques jours plus tard Conrad va
apprendre dans la presse que le Stern a
dépensé 9 millions de dutchmk pour tous
ces faux qu'ils ont achetés et Conrad il
sait que lui il a pas reçu 9 millions de
dutchmk
alors il va se rendre à la police de
Hambourg vraiment et il va faire des
déclarations des aveux il va tout
raconter parce qu'il est tellement en
colère contre le journaliste contre
edeman qu'il veut expliquer à la police
que edeman savait que les journaux et
les documents étaient des faux et que
c'est comme ça qu'il a pu se jouer de
lui et et empocher autant d'argent on
n'est pas sur une des stratégies les
plus brillantes de sa part le
journaliste est arrêté le lendemain le
21 août 1984 un procès sourvre contre
ces deux hommes et là c'est complètement
surréaliste alors Conrad lui est Rabi
d'être au centre de l'attention he c'est
toujours un chatcheur un beau parleur
qui aime bien s'ventter des vies alors
il capotine comme ça avec les jurés et
cetera avec les magistrats de son côté
ed deman commence à présenter des
théories complètement fumeuses puis les
deux vont commencer à s'insulter à se
traiter d'escrot de voleur et cetera le
verdict est rendu un an après le 8
juillet 1985 et Dean va être condamné à
4 ans et 8 mois de prison et Conrad va
tre condamné à 4 ans et 6 mois de prison
en fait l' inégralité ou du moins la
plus grosse des responsabilités elle est
remise sur le Stern qui n'a effectué
aucune vérification et qui a pas pris
les précautions nécessaires qu'a pas
prévenu les autorités ce qui n'empêche
pas les deux hommes évidemment d'aller
piurger leur peine Conrad Cujo va
piurger sa peine mais pas complètement
il va sortir en 1987 à cause d'un cancer
qu'il avait au larinx il va ouvrir une
galerie d'art à Stuttgart et vendre des
copies des tableaux de Hitler de mirau
de monnaie de rambrante mais là il est
un peu plus malin évidemment il fait une
double signature sur les tableaux la
sienne et celle de l'artiste originale
il est même pendant un moment devenu un
artiste à la mode avec ses vrais faux
tableaux pourtant en 1990 il va être
condamné de nouveau pour un trafic de
faux permis ce mec n'arrête jamais il a
l'escroquerie dans le sang et l'histoire
de Conrad s'arrêtera lors de son décès
en 2000 et Doman a pigé sa peine il a
continué sa vie avec des minimas sociaux
cribl et dette a priori il serait
toujours en vie j'ai pas eu de
confirmation de ça mais c'est quelque
chose qu'il se dit c'est à confirmer
quant au Stern ils affirment qu'ils ont
gagné plus de 20000 abonnés 20000
lecteurs et que du coup ils n'ont pas
perdu un seul centime dans cette affaire
j'ai quand même du mal à le croire mais
c'est ce qui déclare je crois qu'au
final personne n'a vraiment été honnête
dans cette histoire tout le monde a
voulu tromper un petit peu la loi pour
essayer d'avoir quelque chose d'original
en tout cas quelque chose qui avait une
potentielle valeur marchande mais sans
rester du bon côté de l'histoire je vous
le disais au début de la vidéo si vous
voulez faire des cadeaux qui valent pas
9 millions de Dutch Mark je vous
recommande 3 originaux que j'ai pu créer
il y a mon jeu de société mon premier
jeu arnaque bluff et diamant ça rentre
un peu dans la thématique qui est sorti
le mois dernier là vous le voyez devant
vous il y en a un dans la description il
y a mon dernier livre qui était sorti au
mois de mai de cette année votre idée va
devenir une réalité et surtout si vous
voulez faire plaisir avec du réel avec
de l'éphémère avec du spectacles vivant
il y a mon spectacle de mentalisme
d'humour et de science là vous voyez
toutes les villes de la tournée c'est de
janvier à juin 2024 c'est la 2e et
dernière saison et là vous voyez un
petit peu une carte de France on a
privilégié les villes où j'étais pas
allé évidemment dans la première saison
donc maintenant c'est c'est à vous de
faire le reste du chemin merci d'avoir
regardé la vidéo à très bientôt
Ciao